and as you've been hearing leaders of
the greek far-right golden dawn party
have been found guilty of running a
criminal group
thousands of protesters gathered outside
the court to hear the verdict
and police have fired tear gas to break
up the demonstrators
let's get more on that story our
correspondent john cerapolis is live
in athens clearly strong feeling amongst
people about this case it's been a long
time coming
talk us through firstly what was
announced by the court today
well the two most important decisions
were the guilty verdict for yogurt
the murderer of bible speeches he is the
man whom security and surveillance
cameras captured
driving up to the point where the rapper
bible species stood
on the night of 17 september 2013
expecting evidently a physical
altercation with right wingers but not a
merger attempt
he walks up to him past two policemen
and stabbed him twice in the chest
police seem to have been so confused
about what happened
that no one intervened to stop this
there was a total of eight police
at the scene at that time and they even
attempted
to arrest the murdered man he was still
alive
and with his dying breath he pointed to
his killer and told them what had
happened and showed the police his
wounds and that is why
ruby gas was arrested that night
otherwise police seem to have had
no clear understanding of what happened
because it happened so fast
that man has now been condemned as
guilty of murder
which carries a statutory sentence of
life imprisonment here in greece
the second very important decision was
that
all 18 members of the golden dawn
party who were elected to parliament in
2012
have been judged guilty of participating
in a criminal
organization this is the key charge
that the government and the prosecutors
had banked on
in order to put golden dawn away as a
group
eight of those 18 mps are additionally
guilty
of forming a criminal organization which
carries
as we understand it a minimum of 10
years in prison
after those decisions were made there
was absolute mayhem here outside the
courtroom
both on this plaza where i saw the
mother of the murdered rapper pavlos
visas calling out
her son's name and uh evidently jubilant
that the family has been vindicated in
this five and a half year long legal
battle
to have not only the murderer put away
but also the party
that motivated that killing meanwhile
thousands of left-wing supporters and
opponents of golden dawn to my left on
alexanders avenue they had shut down
this entire section of town
uh were were cheering uh and
were clearly jubilant at the verdicts to
the point where the police felt they had
to be dispersed
and just moments ago we had clouds of
tear gas
sweep over this plaza here um and stun
grenades were going off in our immediate
vicinity
the crowd has now dispersed but there
seems still to be lots of people in the
side streets
around us that we can see there is
nothing yet resembling normalcy here
traffic has been cut off there are
people in the streets
obviously this is a decision that had
been awaited
with great fervor for a very long time
and it seems to have gone down
very well indeed in greek society john
it's worth
reminding people this was a party that
was in parliament for seven
years explain the wider significance of
this verdict
the important thing was not to banish
the party
the party if it had been banned as a
political force
uh could have simply changed its name
and carried on and stood for re-election
also
such an approach a political approach
wouldn't have
got its 18 mps out of parliament they
could have stayed on as independents
independent of the original party the
important thing
was to judge the party guilty
of being a criminal organization
and a militia in the guise of a
political party
in other words uh a falling foul of
article 187 of the penal code
it is under that article that they have
now been found guilty
and that shuts down both the individuals
and the organization it doesn't address
the ideology of
far-right the fascism because that is
problematic under the greek constitution
but it does address the substance of the
matter
which was not only getting rid of
golden dawn from parliament but also
making sure they don't reappear
to a certain extent that goal had been
served in the latest election
when the party did not make the three
percent uh popular vote threshold in
order to enter
uh the chamber of representatives so
they do not have seats in parliament
anyway but this is also a legal
vindication and safeguard
that they cannot come back they cannot
stand for re-election certainly not the
uh condemned individuals and certainly
not that political
organization that is known as golden daw
so
the party i would say the significance
of today's decision is that the party
has been defeated
both politically in the latest election
and now legally as well
john cerrapolis there for us in athens
many thanks